METE ATAMEL: Istio
is an open platform
to connect, manage, and
secure microservices.
Let's see what it takes
to install and run
Istio on Google
Kubernetes Engine, or GKE.
First, create a
Kubernetes cluster
on GKE with G Cloud Container
Clusters Create command.
Make sure your cluster is
using Kubernetes 1.9 or newer,
and grant admin permissions
to the current G Cloud user.
Now, download the
latest Istio version
and add Istio CTL command
line tool to your path.
Now we are ready to install
Istio's core components.
We will install the
optional auth components.
This creates Istio
system namespace
and deploys the four primary
control plane components--
Pilot, Mixer, Ingress,
and Certificate Authority.
Let's quickly verify
the installation.
And that's it.
That's all it takes to
install Istio in GKE.